[Music]
i am so excited right now because we are
on a brand new season three set for
outlander we are and you're gonna give
me a little tour yeah
so this is their living room where all
the living happens
wonderful as you would think brianna
brianna is kind of messy so we have some
of brianna's
weird creepy toys
how would you describe claire's
decorating style you know in season one
one of the things that claire always
said was that she never had a home that
she could put a voz into so now i think
that she has her home she is a
knick-knack collector but this is one of
my favorite things okay when claire
comes back from the hospital you know
she comes in makes herself a nice
cocktail
a nice stiff drink yeah a stiff drink
unwinds after a tough day of you know in
surgery and all of that it's a stressful
job it is very strong i mean she's a
surgeon in the 60s as a woman that's
pretty amazing she's crushing it we
should move into the study so this is
the dining room
or study okay now you know when frank is
around it's his study i was gonna say
there's lots of books in here it's it's
feeling like a frank room yeah
frank's into his antiquities yes um
yeah
we let him have this room every man
should have a man cave yeah so
i like it i like it a lot but so how are
you feeling about season three and how
cool is it that you get to have a brand
new set like this that's just around
claire it's been
i guess quite interesting to find how
does this character live
when she's lost the main love of her
life but you know claire's a survivor
and
as we know she doesn't grieve for 20
years she becomes a surgeon and she has
a beautiful home with about 20 different
shades of blue in it so
now i know that you've been working a
lot closer with sophie this year what
has it been like for you to kind of tap
into your maternal instincts it's been
great i mean sophie is amazing she's an
amazing actress it's i always forget
that she's so young because she's just a
really smart so self-possessed um girl
and we had such a short space of time to
try and accomplish that at the end of
season two so to be able to have that
time this season and really get to know
each other has been really great they
they get to know each other as adults as
well which is really nice i love that
yeah how are you feeling about finally
reuniting with sam and sharing those
claire and jamie scenes 20 years later
well i think it's going to be great you
know i think we've all been very excited
about that part of the story this season
it's a unique challenge as an actor to
play a character who lives for 20 years
and then to reconnect with the person
that they they knew and and try and do
that as different people in many ways or
people with very different experiences
so
yeah that's going to be interesting
but it's great you know it's sam and i
we've worked so closely together for
three years that it's been really
strange not having him around every day
although it's meant that we've both had
some time off so i think both of us have
enjoyed that part of it yeah talk to me
about claire's wardrobe because we're
gonna get to see so many different
decades yeah there's 40s there's 50s 60s
it was great fun with terry we sort of
had a day where she just had these rails
and rails of clothes and it was like
being in the best vintage shop ever i
mean the 40s stuff i love yeah um and
60s is just super glamorous and you know
some of the outfits that i get to wear
are just amazing so as we keep saying oh
that one might have to fall off the back
of the truck and that one might have to
fall off the back of the truck so
well katrina thank you so much for
giving me a tour of your beautiful home
oh thanks for coming by i'm so excited
i'm gonna have to make you a cocktail
now once they go away uh that would be
amazing yeah now you guys gotta go all
right get out of here
[Music]
you